movies coming out and in the movie you
are contemplating being or Nick wants
you to be in his band and and that's a
big part of the movie hearts beat lab
that's gonna be in theaters June 8th but
original music from the film featuring
vocals from you and Nick gonna be
available the same day as well so you've
got an album coming out that it's mine
isn't that cool yeah yeah he's good you
got a record out yeah I wonder if
they'll have it in like urban outfitters
or something that's how you know you've
made it when you're on it when you're in
Urban Outfitters you know you've made it
yeah go to your urban offers and if they
don't have it say where is hearts beat
loud and if they don't have it make a
fuss and then they're gonna what's that
supposed to what are you supposed to
read what Chrissy I love you there's no
one quite like you you I love you
no that just says Kiersey Clemons will
be
[Applause]
would you say why would you say that
would be such a new innovation if the
guest was like yeah and that's kind of
what happened Kiersey Clemons my name
and then it says something under it for
me to say it looks like right oh yeah
and it looks like somebody really wants
you to say
[Applause]
Kiersey Clemons we'll be right back
you